last speaker is christina you christina
is an assistant professor at
cornell and a research fellow in the
reinforcement learning program
thanks prasad um so in this
talk we're going to look at the problem
of episodic reinforcement learning with
continuous state in action spaces
in which we have an agent interacting
with an environment and
the dynamics and the reward of function
associated to the environment are
unknown so the agent is trying to
learn the optimal policy as it interacts
with the environment but in this
setting we want to deal with the case of
a continuous state in action space
where you have to figure out how to
reduce the complexity of your space in
order to learn
so one approach is to use parametric
function approximators but these
suffer model mismatch loss and require
prior knowledge of the structure in
order to
guarantee that that
guarantee your convergence with respect
to a particular model class
so instead we're going to look at
non-parametric
assumptions on the value function with
respect to some known metric
and next slide
so one naive approach to deal with the
continuous space is to
simply uniformly discretize the space to
map it to a tabular
mdp and often time this this uh
discretization
parameter epsilon is chosen as a
function of the time horizon to balance
the approximation error and the cost of
solving the tableau ndp
this discretization can be very
expensive though
next slide so
we propose an adaptive discrimination
algorithm which
essentially starts with a course
discussion of the space
and only refines the partition as needed
in a data dependent way
so this generates kind of a sequence of
tabular ndps that
that locally refines the the discussion
only in areas of high value
so this reduces memory requirements and
accelerates the learning
um and i'll illustrate some properties
of the algorithm just through
simulations
next slide so in this problem
um we're consider as a simple oil
discovery problem where there's an agent
surveying a map in search of hidden oil
deposits and it collects reward
um according to a um
the cost of transportation cost cost of
traveling on this
map as well as a surveying reward
um related to how close you are to this
uh kind of hidden oil
um and to make it easy to visualize
we've chosen um
the unit interval to be the state in
action space um
on the bottom left these two plots um
are illustrating the the q function
which is the
expected value of the optimal policy for
being in a state in action
pair and green denotes areas of higher
value and red denotes area of low value
and overlaid on top of these plots
is the partition that our algorithm
discovers so
the left is for the model free version
of algorithm the right is for the model
based version of our algorithm
and you can see that the partition our
algorithm generates does in fact
focus in on the regions of high value
and on the right side
on the right top plot you can see that
when you that when you compare the
the reward a collective reward from our
algorithm as opposed to a naive uniform
discretization algorithm um our
algorithm in fact performs much better
converging faster to the optimal policy
and on the bottom right it's showing
that our algorithm impacts has
a significant gains in memory savings so
it has a significantly smaller size of
partition and next slide
so in this plot i'm just showing that uh
we chose a different function for the
reward function that's
significantly more peaked um meaning
that the
as you can see in the q function um that
there is a
narrow region with high rewards so it's
kind of looking for a needle in a
haystack
but our algorithm is indeed able to kind
of locate this narrow region of high
reward as opposed to the uniform epsilon
that
um does not converge and in fact does
not achieve the optimum policy as you
can see
from the reward plot on the upper right
um okay so that's
uh that's that's it there's one more
example in the next slide but i'll um
just show this slide and not talk about
it welcome to
ask me about it in the next breakout
sessions